3 mètres de paille peint à la bombe et
soutenu par des piquets de clôture
difficile de manquer l’œuvre de cet
agriculteur de buzancée depuis la route
et c'est exactement l'effet escompté bon
on prend toute la paille nous pour nos
animaux donc et on fait pas mal de
convois sur les routes donc c'est pour
faire voir aux gens d'une certaine
manière que Marie qu'on les embête sur
la route avec nos chargements de paille
on sait faire autre chose que de les
embêter avec notre paille comme lui une
dizaine d'agriculteurs c'est improvisé
sculpteur à l'occasion d'un défi lancé
il y a deux semaines par le syndicat
majoritaire dans la profession depuis
les géants de paille ont chacun hérité
d'un surnom et se sont forgés une petite
réputation sur les réseaux sociaux
certaines personnes qui pensent au monde
agricole quelque part
sur notre côté
et ça c'est important bah oui un peu
si c'est quand même nous qui les
nourrissons pour l'oublier
mettre à l'honneur le monde agricole
changer son image auprès du grand public
l'opération de communication nourrit de
grandes ambitions on est responsable de
beaucoup de choses alors que moi je
dirais qu'on est la solution de beaucoup
de choses c'est l'inverse dire que même
si on a une activité qui peut paraître
polluante sur certains points c'est
aussi une activité qui est capable de
dépolluer et ça on en prend pas assez
consciences quand vous voyez ce que peut
représenter l'agriculture dans le
département de l'Indre c'est pas neutre
il y a des emplois derrière il y a une
activité économique l'opération vise
également à inciter le plus grand nombre
à consommer des produits français les
sculptures devraient rester en place
jusqu'à la fin de l'été